Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
The verses that we heard for
the first and beginning opening verses
of
this chapter of the Quran
is referred to as
orah
And this is the first chapter of the
Quran
that was revealed to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
upon his arrival in Medina.
Upon his arrival in Medina when he left
from Mecca to Medina
the first chapter revealed to him was
Abbas
tells us that the first chapter revealed
to the prophet Sam
upon his arrival to Medina was.
Other companions mention that it was the
last surah revealed to him in Mecca
and some scholars
view that it is one of the chapters that
was revealed more than once.
But they all agree that it was either
the last chapter of Mecca or the first
that was revealed to him in Medina.
That's really significant.
Why is that? When we look at the history
of legislation in Islam,
Mecca and Medina,
those are two very different eras.
And the scholars
starting with the companions
gave a lot of attention
and meticulously documented
which chapter and even which verses were
revealed in Mecca and which were
revealed in Medina. to the point that
most of the mus that are printed today
have in the index or the table of
contents or even at the page
marker of each chapter it will either
say Mecci or Medini meaning that this
chapter was revealed during the Meccan
era or it was revealed during the Medina
era. This is not a reference to the
place where these chapters were
revealed. When the scholars say this
chapter is mechi
or this chapter is Medani, it's not a
reference to the place.
It is a reference to the era in which
this chapter was revealed. Was it the
era of Mecca or the era of Medina? Why
is that so important? It's very
important because a lot of things
changed between Mecca and Medina
because of those who the verses and
chapters were speaking to predominantly
in Mecca as opposed to Medina.
In Mecca,
the most
important
tenants of Islam and most basic
constructs or most basic pillars of
belief were focused on and detailed in
Mecca.
And the only two pillars of Islam that
were that were given to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam in Mecca before his
hij were the first two. the testimony
ofahill.
And then way later during
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam was
commanded to make the five daily
prayers. Anyone can tell us when is
what year?
Take a shot.
How many years did he spend in Mecca?
Huh?
13 years, right? 13 years in Mecca.
What year did the
happen?
You got to talk louder.
Eight. No, we only have 12 choices now.
So,
anyone else?
Six. There's a there's different
opinions. Some some historians say
three, but the majority of the scholars
and historians of Islam
tell us that
was in the 10th year after before the
10th year after his prophethood.
That's right after the ninth year. What
was the ninth year? The ninth year is
what is referred to by historians as
right the sad year or the year of grief
because Abu Talib passed away and
Khadijah both passed away months apart
in the ninth year. And so Allah never
takes something without replacing it
with something equal or better
if it is not being taken as a
punishment. And so yes, he took from him
Abu Talib because he was his his journey
didn't need them anymore. But he was
then given
and given five daily prayers. But
overall, those were the only two pillars
of Islam in Mecca.
In Medina, the rest of the pillars of
Islam were commanded. And that is where
the details of law started to be
legislated in Medina, right?
Zaka,
fasting, Hajj and Omrah. And also the
rules and laws and regulations of
marriage, the rules and laws and
regulations
of transactions, of sales, of
ownership,
of hud of punishment.
All of these things were detailed and
began in Medina.
And so it's important for us to know
what was the first thing of that era
that was revealed. Meaning you have to
see it from the prophet's perspective.
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam. He arrives
at Medina and now he is speaking to a
people that are predominantly Muslim.
They are predominantly Muslim or they
are on the verge of becoming Muslim. And
now whatever details or laws they are
commanded with, they're going to uphold
because we've spent 13 years purifying
our hearts and preparing
ourselves for the details. So from his
perspective when he made his hij
the first revelation to come to him to
mark the beginning of those details and
laws was
that is what all the laws of Islam are
predicated upon.
So the beginning of those laws, the laws
that have to do between you and I,
between a man and his wife, between a
merchant and his customer, between a
landowner and his neighbor, between a
farmer and his crops, between a shepherd
and his herd. All of these things were
based and built and started with these
verses.
If we want to speak about the rights
that we have over each other, we begin
by looking at these rights and taking
these laws upon the basis of
woe to the
is plural for
Allah goes on to explain who are. So he
says woe to this type of person. This
type of person has a terrible punishment
awaiting him when he meets his creator.
What is what who are these people? these
dreadful individuals.
Allah tells us
those who when they
seek their rights from others, they want
them completely.
Not one little right missing, not one
grain of rice, not one morsel of salt,
not one thing missing. I want my money's
worth.
But when it's time for them to give the
rights of others,
they only give the bare minimum and they
take whatever extra they can get. They
try to take skim a little off the top.
So they expect forgiveness from others,
but they have no forgiveness for anyone
else.
They want their rights completely
but they are unwilling to give the
rights of others. This person is
referred to as a
this word
linguistically where does it come from?
What is its etmology?
The scholars tell us that
the Arab linguists tell us that al- is
taken from the root word
And
or
is the extra little amount that is found
on top of a heap when its volume is
measured. So let me give you an example
of that. Let's say we take a a a cup
of rice, right? Some of the middle of
that cup, if it's completely full, will
go past the top a little bit, right?
That heap on top.
And if you wipe your hand over the top
of it and level it with the rim of the
cup, that extra that comes off the top,
that is referred to as a.
And so a is someone who eagerly and
unremittently
seeks that extra. I need to have that
and I will sneak it in wherever I can
and I will also sneak it out of whoever
I have to give it to. This is where the
essence of this word comes from. So a
maf is a person who seeks his full
rights from others,
but he as long as he can and get away
with it, he or she will take away or
deplete the rights of others for their
own gain. Even if it is petty and even
if it is something
very trivial.
If it's a penny for me, it's better in
my pocket than his. This kind of
thought, this kind of attitude, this is
a mut. Now, that is in a physical
transaction of volume or weight, right?
However, the meaning is much more broad
than just that. It's referring to anyone
who seeks their full rights from others
but do not give others their full rights
in return.
Who is more important for us to learn?
We can't learn everything together at
the same time. We have to learn one
thing before the other. When I come to
ask and what is most important to me if
I believe in Allah in the last day, what
is more important for me to know?
My rights that are owed to me or the
rights of others upon me?
What's the answer?
It's more important for me to learn the
rights of others because that's what
I'll be asked about on the day of
judgment,
not my rights and what am I owed. This
is a disease.
It's a disease.
It's a disease that is taken straight
out of the playbook of the hypocrites.
And it is a disease almost taken
directly from the rats and the cockroach
because this person has no problem
degrading himself
and taking away from his dignity to get
all worked up over a grain of rice
because it's not about the grain of
rice. It's the principle they'll say.
And so this idea of what am I owed and
this obsession with what what do I get
out of it? That is exactly what the
hypocrites base their religion upon is
what can I gain from becoming Muslim.
Not what can I offer, not what what's
what am I responsible for, not what am I
supposed to do, it's what can I get out
of it. And that's why Allah describes
the hypocrites in the Quran that when
the Muslims win, they say, "Weren't we
always with you? I'm one of youallah."
But when the Muslims lose, they stand
back and say, "This doesn't concern me.
This is none of my business."
Right? And so it goes.
When it's time to celebrate, they show
up. when it's time to roll their sleeves
up, they disappear cockroaches.
And so this is
the essence of the attitude of a
notice when Allah revealed it to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam as if to
say now I'm going to teach you how to
perfect all matters amongst each other.
However, the responsibility of each and
every one of you is not to police others
on your rights, but to get your own self
to fulfill the rights of others. Focus
on that. And if we can just get the
majority of you, not every single
person, but if we can get the majority
of us focused on what is required from
us rather than what is for us, we will
have no direction to go but up. That's
the idea. That is why it was revealed to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. Look
at how this sickness, this illness has
seeped in and crept into the Muslim
psyche. I tell you what, if I sat in
this chair right now and talked about
the rights of the husband over the wife,
I will get almost stoned to death. I
will be chased out of the masid by
sisters telling me, "What about the men?
What if they don't do what they're
supposed to do?" We're not talking about
that. Why is it that we cannot learn
what is required from us? And also if I
sat in this chair right now and talked
about the rights of the wife over her
husband, 20 brothers are going to stop
me and tell me, "But you know what, you
left out the rights of the husband over
the wife because a lot of, you know,
blah blah blah blah blah. This is not
our subject. Why are we so adverse to
learning what is required from us? It's
a disease. It's a sickness that we have
to work out of ourselves.
No one is going to be in his right mind
and have his religion intact and dignity
intact and expect to get all that he is
owed in this dunya. A person who
believes that is living in fantasy land.
It doesn't work that way. There's a rope
between people. When that person pulls
it, you let go a little bit. It's okay.
And when you pull it, they let go a
little bit. And this is how marriages
succeed. This is how brotherhood , you
know, is maintained. This is how good
things are made.
But everyone becomes obsessed with what
they're owed. And so you ask a brother,
what are the rights of a wife over her
husband? Silence. Very few brothers know
the answer to that question. But ask
them, "What are the rights of the
husband over the wife?" They can recite
it to you as if the books are open in
front of them. And vice versa. You ask
the sisters, "What are the rights of a
husband over her wife over his wife?"
Well, you know, general generalized,
"What are the rights of a wife over her
husband?"
specifics, details, knowledge will gush
forth. Why? Because we are obsessed with
what is for us, not what is upon us.
However, we should always, a person who
believes in Allah in the last day is
terrified of not knowing what he owes
other people because he doesn't want to
meet Allah having to owe anyone.
However, a person who is more focused on
the dunya, they will be more focused on
what is for them.
And so in closing, we'll end with this
narration.
The prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us in he told the
companions once
he said after my passing he's speaking
to the companions he said after my
passing there are going to be leaders
that are going to take hold of the
government over you and they will govern
you in a very one-sided manner. They
will take all of what is theirs and not
give you what is yours. And they'll even
take what is supposed to be yours and
put it in their own pockets.
And so the companions asked, "What
should we do? How should we respond
to a governing force over us that
deprivives us our rights but takes their
own? And the prophet Sam
said
[Silence]
He said,
"Give the rights that are upon you by
Allah. Fulfill what is upon you and ask
Allah for what is yours."
And he added in another narration,
be patient and maintain said patience
until you meet me on the lake on the day
of judgment. The lake that comes from
alther that gush gushes forth from
Jenna. If you are patient and you
fulfill the rights of others not when
they only when they give you your
rights. No, you fulfill the rights of
others especially
when they don't fulfill your rights
because you're dealing with Allah.
You're not dealing with human beings.
You're dealing with Allah. If you
maintain that patience and that moral
compass,
you will meet me on the lake of Alcar on
the day of judgment. That is the place
where when we come, if we are allowed on
the shores and the banks of that lake,
the prophet Muhammad Sam
will give us to drink from his own hand
sai.
Now,
what kicks in? What kicks in is all of
the brainwashing that the Muslims have
been through in the last couple of
centuries. I mean, we've all come from
countries ravaged by colonialism,
ravaged by television and thoughts that
aren't our own and don't come from our
book. We live in that time. And so the
idea is,
you know, this is this is what rich
people tell poor people to keep them
poor, right? Stuff that. Things
taken straight out of the Marx brothers
playbook.
This is not what our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam has commanded us. The dunya
will never be perfect. It's never going
to be a perfect place. There's always
going to be a problem with someone no
matter who it is. But what the only
person we can change is ourselves. And
so you never want to be caught as the
person pointing your finger whilst in
reality fingers point back at you in the
court of Allah. We ask Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to teach us those rights that
are upon us to grant us the strength to
give those rights not only when we are
given our rights in return but
especially when we are not fulfilled our
rights. We ask Allah to give us that
deep deep conviction of belief that we
will be rewarded and compensated by
Allah. That we will be entered into
paradise and that we will be included in
the intercession of Muhammad Sam.
and a Muhammad while early. He was